if you've got a face mastercard thinks
you've got everything you need to make
contactless payments in supermarkets i'm
going to find out more
today we are announcing completely new
biometric checkout program what it does
is it allows you
as a consumer
to pay with your face or
pay by waving your hand
when you check out from a physical store
the one question i've had about
biometrics is
if i forget my password i can change my
password
i've only got one face
so
what is the risk that my face
becomes compromised and suddenly you
know i can't get a new face the way it
works is your
registration when that is done for this
program
actually tokenizes your credentials so
your face
and the details of your face actually
never leave
your device excellent can i see that now
in a demo i'm very excited to see this
i've heard a lot about this checkout
system so
could i hold up a photo let's say
of my brother who looks a bit like me
could i hold up a print out of his face
a photograph to try and trick this or is
there more technology built in that
makes that impossible there's more
technology that's built in that makes
that impossible so we have multiple
layers of security and privacy controls
embedded both in the hardware and the
software technology that's scanning
right so it has to be a 3d image
and then all of the algorithms that are
built when we are tokenizing that
biometric data are all built to be able
to
you know identify uh the right person
for that right payment card who owns the
data about my face i appreciate it
stored as a sort of as a fingerprint as
an id rather than as a
replicable photograph of my face but
where is that store do i keep that does
a retailer keep that do you keep that
great question the data first and
foremost gets abstracted and tokenized
the underlying biometric data gets
deleted so the only thing that remains
is a token a representation of the
biometric data that gets encrypted and
then that's getting stored by whoever is
operating by a metric checkout system
can i have a go uh you certainly can
yeah we you start you ask so many
questions we skip that part
okay i'm at the checkout i've got a
basket full of beans and bananas
i'm gonna register my face
i'm going to get registered
um
fine let's set it up
okay so i'm going to scan my face shall
i hold it up
[Music]
i'm so happy to be buying bananas
okay and i can use any of these any of
those um i feel like a platinum person
today okay
um
finish
so i'm all set you're all set so that's
that's the registration portion of this
done oh there i am look there you are
excellent
okay okay
so next step
i'm at the terminal
[Music]
oh that was quick
that was it right that was it okay
and i made a saving i don't think i have
any more questions um my face clearly is
my debit card now so thank you very much
for that